اذا انتهى الامر بان ارتكب روني الذي كان
دوما سريع الغضب مخالفه عندما داس على
المدافع البرتغالي ريكاردو كار فاليو ووقع
في مشكله بالطبع وعلى الفور هب رونالدو
للضغط على الحكم كي يخرج زميله في النادي
من المباراه في شكل الرئيسي رونالدو ليس
غبيا وكان يعرف ان قدره المنتخب الانجليزي
على الفوز تتناقص كثيرا من دون روني ما
يزيد فرصه البرتغال بالتاهل للنهائي في
شكل كبير وعلى الرغم من ان الحكم صرح
لاحقا ان روني اخرج من المباراه بسبب
المخالفه وليس لاي سبب اخر الا انه بدا ان
قياده رونالدو لحمله تحريض الحكم نيابه عن
المنتخب البرتغالي هي ما اقنعت الحكم
باخراج روني من المباراه ومن ثم الغمزه
التي لا يستطيع احد النسيانها والتي
التقطت على الكاميرا بينما كانت البطاقه
الحمراء تشهر في وجه روني وكان يخرج من
الملعب بخطى متفاقله غمز رونالدو بعينه
ناظرا لمقاعد بدلاء البرتغال واقتنع
الرجال والنساء الانجليز بان رونالدو هو
الذي تسبب بخروج روني توا
اثار ذلك تساؤلات عن قدره رونالدو وروني
على اللعب معا في ملعب اولد ترافورد بعد
الحادثه حقيقه بدا ان الامر قد يتحول الى
عداوه شديده ضمن غرفه تبديل الملابس في
اولد ترافورد وكان لذلك تاثير هائل بالطبع
في رد فعل المشجعين الانجليز على رونالدو
فقد تولدت فجاه عداوه نحوه لم تكن من قبل
فحتى داعموا النوادي الخصوم كانوا قد
تقبلوا على مضد انهم يشاهدون لاعبا عظيما
ومن المرجح انهم استمتعوا كثيرا بمشاهده
لاعبه رغم انه كان يهزم فرقهم هزيمه ساحقه
وفجاه اصبح رونالدو يقابل بهتافات
الاستنكار اينما ذهب وبدا ان بعض مشجعي
مانشستر يونايتد انقلبوا ضده
وقد تطلب التجاوز ذلك الموسم قوه شخصيه
هائله من قبل رونالدو حتما حيث تحول الى
شرير الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز في شكل
مبالغ فيه رغم الكره الموجه نحو رونالدو
بعد عودته من كاس العالم 2006 كان موسم
الفين 2006 الفين 2007 مليئا بلحظات محطمه
للارقام القياسيه بالنسبه اليه حيث كسر
حاجز العشرين هدفا للمره الاولى واحرز
هدفه الخمسين مع مانشستر يونايتد وفاز
بجائزه افضل لاعب شاب للعام وجائزه لعب
العام من اتحاد نقاد كره القدم وعلاوه على
ذلك كله ساعد يونايتد على الفوز بلقب
الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز
مع نهايه عام 2007 تم ترشيح رونالدو بفضل
مسيرته المذهله مع يونايتد الفوز بجائزه
افضل لاعب كره قدم في العالم متنافسا مع
كاكا وميسي كما تم ترشيحه للفوز بجائزه
الكره الذهبيه الاولى لكن للاسف حصل على
المركز الثاني امام الفائز كاكا وعلى
المركز الثالث في جائزه افضل لاعب كره قدم
في العالم في سن الثالثه والعشرين فقط
اصبح واحدا من افضل اللاعبين في العالم
وكان عام 2008 سيكون مليئا اكثر
بالانجازات بالنسبه الى رونالدو
اذا اردنا العثور على موسم رونالدو الذهبي
في اولد ترافورد من المرجح ان يكون موسم
2007 2008 والمفارقه في الامر هو انه
استهل الموسم باخراجه من مباراه ضد
بورتموث بعد ان نطح الخصم براسه وعوقب
بالحظر لثلاث مباريات لكنه تحول الى موسم
مذهل بعد ذلك فور عودته بعد الحظر سجل
هدفه الاول للموسم في لشبونه ضد سبورتنج
وهو ناديه الاول في دوري الابطال وبعد ذلك
اخذ يحرز الاهداف كل اسبوع تقريبا مسجلا
42 هدفا مع يونايتد في ذلك الموسم
والهاتريك الاول له مع النادي اخذ يحطم
الارقام القياسيه في شتى النواحي وفي خضم
هذه الحمله المبهره التي شهدنا فيها تطور
اللاعب اكثر فاكثر ترددت الهمسات الاولى
في شان ريال مدريد